Many legends surround the beginnings of Christmas tree decorations.
One of the most popular such legends proposes that it began with Saint Boniface,...
..in Germany around the 1st century.
St. Boniface happened upon a pagan ritual involving an oak tree,...
...and enraged, cut it down.
A miracle occurred when out of the roots rose a young fir tree.
St. Boniface then believed the tree to be a gift from God...
...and as such, deserving of adoration.
Another purports Martin Luther is "The Father of the Christmas tree".
And still others credit the Egyptians with this well-loved tradition.
Regardless of origin though, it is clear that the custom has changed...
...and evolved throughout  the centuries...
...and become the family affair we look forward to today.